this is a production of cornell
university
so what i really did at cornell uh was
be involved in the lettuce project and
this is a
picture of of one of the setups that
that we looked at
and the idea was it was funded by the
the nysec the local power company
nyserda and at the time eserco
energy research and development
corporation i think it was
they were interested in selling more
power more electricity and and we of
course felt that if you want to grow a
crop in a relatively dark environment in
upstate new york you can only do that
successfully if you add lots of
supplemental lighting
so we picked lettuce
and i don't remember anymore exactly why
we picked lettuce we thought at the time
i think that was a great idea because it
was
a so-called simple crop to grow that
turned out not to be the case
we picked lettuce
and the objective of the work was to try
to grow it as fast as possible
so have minimal time in the greenhouse
and also have it finished in the same
period of time so in the independent of
the weather conditions we wanted to have
the lettuce finish at the same
date so the number of days it took from
seeding to harvesting was always
supposed to be the same in our system so
you have to keep that in mind when you
think about our our system and the
approach that we took
the reasons of course is that greenhouse
space is very expensive and
and so you need to get the crop in and
out quickly and we couldn't wait uh
particularly when you think about
changing lighting conditions we couldn't
wait we didn't afford ourselves to wait
and grow a crop over more days when the
light conditions were not favorable so
supplemental lighting was used and you
see here the setup that we used
uh using high pressure sodium lamps in a
specifically designed array to get high
uniformity
and the highest intensity possible
given
the limited resource in terms of
electricity that we wanted to use for
for growing this crop
so one of the the results of that work
was here you see
a graph that shows you the accumulated
light conditions since seeding on the
horizontal axis on the vertical axis you
see the shoot dry mass or shoot dry
weight and you get a very nice linear
line not surprising when you think about
a crop like lettuce that is a vegetative
crop
so there's not really all that much
significant about this graph except for
the fact that you're looking at 35 data
points and each of those data points was
a single treatment and each treatment
started with about 800 seats
so the the amount of work that went into
giving you this graph this this very
nice linear relationship
was quite significant and many people
were involved in this effort and it took
many many
hours of work to to get all these data
points for this graph
another thing we looked at was was leaf
area versus
the horizontal axis
shoot fresh mass
and on the other
on the right hand side on the vertical
axis we looked at the dry mass so we got
nice correlations between leaf area
and and
shoot fresh mass as well as the dry mass
and the fresh mass
again not particularly surprising except
i want to mention that if you look at
the blue line you see a very nice linear
relationship between dry mass and fresh
mass and this resulted very quickly in
significant discussions with
particularly with professor langhans
because the staff obviously was more
interested in taking the fresh mass and
not do the
tedious dry weight measurements dry mass
measurements
but he stood his grounds and we lost out
and so we did
continue
uh weighing uh plants after they went
through the drying cycle and and
we had to do a lot of extra work because
of that but
to his credit that also meant that we
had better results in the end and more
publishable results
when we were done
so everything was going nice and
smoothly until we hit a significant
problem and the problem was called
tipwork
and tipburn is a physiological disorder
and again i'm an engineer so you have to
ask the plant physiologist for more
specific details but my understanding is
that it is caused by a calcium
deficiency the plant is growing very
rapidly
and calcium is not taken up quickly
enough by the roots and not
taken to the young
rapidly expanding leaf tissue and as a
result we see die back of that leaf
tissue and you get a lettuce plant that
looks much like this and of course
although you get the dry weight
accumulation you can't sell the plant
because nobody in the right mind would
go to wegmans and buy this this head of
lettuce
so we we were stuck we were trying to
push the plants as fast as we could
to try to get them out of the greenhouse
as quickly as possible
but we didn't reach
we couldn't grow and past a certain
point because we started seeing this tip
burn issue from happening
so we had many discussions about what we
could do about it we looked at papers
and we found a paper from colleagues in
japan
that actually blew
air on lettuce plants to try to increase
plant transpiration and therefore
increase the the uptake and transport of
calcium from the roots to the young
growing tips
and they seem to have some success and
so we talked about
how we could do this envisioning a large
greenhouse setup with little tubes that
were blowing air on individual heads of
lettuce and we quickly realized that
this was not going to work in a
practical
system
so i mentioned here we did a covert
experiment and covert i have to explain
was because professor langhans was out
of town at the time
and and um
we had discussed this idea but i think
he wasn't very much in favor of it
and so
we took the opportunity i think he was
either
at a conference or he was
going for winter break in florida and so
we took that opportunity to put
something together very simply and an
inflated plastic tube with little holes
along the side positioned directly
overhead
two rows of lettuce plants and we we
grew the plants and looked at the
results and much to our surprise the the
idea worked perfectly in in fact the
plants that received additional air
supply
with this system did not get any tip
burn where neighboring plants did have
significant amount of tipper
and so
after we saw the result ourselves we
could
report back to professor langest when he
came back from his trip or from his
vacation
uh that indeed we discovered that this
was a great idea and we should
investigate more
and so he then quickly told us then
to use turbulator fans overhead fans
that
could blow large amounts of air
vertically down on the lettuce crop to
help increase plant transpiration and
overcome this this dipper and issue
and so this is what we we started doing
and this is how we overcome the typical
issue issue but to a certain extent
and at certain extent this i'm trying to
show you here in this graph where on the
horizontal axis you look at dry mass
accumulation on the vertical axis you
look at water use we carefully tracked
water use of plants in our system
and we could come up with
these lines and these are
regression lines so they're not the
actual data but the result of the the
data that we collected to try to
polish up the graph a little bit but you
can see here there's different
light treatments that have different
rates of water use
as the plants are growing through the
different stages to final harvest
and so we surmised from this craft that
that you needed to have a minimum rate
of water use or plant transpiration
in order to overcome this tip burn
problem you can see in the top of the
slide that treatments up to 16 moles of
light or so did not
suffer from tip burn where treatments
above that 20 and 22 moles in the bottom
did receive or did experience tip burn
issues
so this is why
if you've been at all familiar with the
cea program this is why
we typically recommend that 16 to 70
moles of light is the limit
using the cornell system for growing
lettuce
because of this different issue and
because of the fact that if you use
additional measures to increase plant
transpiration like these turbulator fans
we can overcome tip burn but only to a
certain extent if you still try to push
the plants even harder you do get the
dry mass accumulation but you don't get
you don't overcome the different issue
we also dabbled in in co2 experiments
where we
enrich the environment and i i say
trading here with quotes and what i mean
with that i want to explain with this
graph
if you look on the
vertical axis you see the shoot dry mass
again
and you see a dark line a black line at
seven grams and that's the the target
weight that we were trying to shoot for
that corresponds if you go back to the
linear relationship between fresh mass
and dry mass that corresponds to a fresh
mass of approximately 150 grams which
was the target mass we were trying to
shoot for so the 7 grams is our target
size of planet we are trying to shoot
for
and if you look then at the different
light intensities indicated by different
colored lines here
and you follow that seven grand line uh
from left to right you see it in the sex
with the 17 moles first at approximately
ambient co2 concentrations of course
this is 20 years ago when co2
concentration ambient was still around
350 right now it's approaching 400.
but as you go further to the right you
see that that horizontal line at 7 grams
intersects with different
lines of of light intensity and they
correspond to different co2
concentrations if you look at the
horizontal axis so what i'm trying to
tell you here is that we found out that
if instead of growing the plants at 17
moles at ambient co2 concentrations you
could also grow a plant at 12 moles
where you had to increase the the co2
concentration to approximately 1300 or
so micro moles per moles or parts per
million
and this is what i mean by trading we
discovered that within limits
you could decide instead of adding more
supplemental lighting which is very
expensive you could you could add or
increase the co2 concentration and get
the same end result
and so this was an interesting
discovery and and i think when you think
about commercial production this can
have some significant implications
because obviously it will be cheaper to
add co2 compared to adding supplemental
lighting
and then all that work resulted in a set
of growth curves we use the second order
exponential polynomial you see the
equation in the box upright
where we only have one
variable the the daily light integral
the amount of light we provided on a
daily basis to the plants that we
provide that light every day to try to
keep the plants at their fixed growing
rate to make sure we reach the target
harvest date
and you can see here for different daily
light integrals what the growth curve
looked like
for the varieties that we were using at
the time which was austenita bib lettuce
we also looked at efficiency
rates uh so how much energy do you need
to provide and what do you get in return
in terms of biomass
and more recently i found a paper by
monteith in that from 1977 that looked
at
efficiency rates in terms of the amount
of light it was intercepted versus the
dry matter production
um
and he looked at at outdoor crops he
looked at apples barley potatoes and
sugar beets and you see these colored
lines here
indicating
the data that he found
and then from this data i can calculate
an average efficiency taking too into
account that the heat of combustion for
dry matter is approximately 7.5
kilojoules per gram so i could look at
the energy that you provided through
sunlight versus the energy that you you
gain from
dry matter production and then you can
calculate an efficiency
and then the little blue line
towards the origin of the graph here is
is the line for our lettuce plants
and now you think that it looks like the
lettuce is not doing so well but you
have to keep in mind that the lettuce
crops that we were growing only required
a 24 day time period in the greenhouse
we grew it for 11 days in the growth
chamber and then 24 more days in the
in the
greenhouse so after
35 days or five weeks the plants were
finished and we reached the 150 gram
fresh matter
freshwater
target harvest size
so if you if you think about this the
outdoor crops can be grown only once in
outdoor season but the greenhouse crops
can be grown actually 15 times in the
same area in a greenhouse so multiply
both axis by 15 and you see that
the greenhouse crop was doing
significantly better than the field
crops
as i mentioned we did lots of
experiments
some were funny and some were
informative one of them that i liked
particularly
was this continuous production in this
case in nft or nutrient film technique
showing you the visual growth curve i
showed you the lines that we that we
calculated from the data that we
collected here you see actually in a
visual representation an actual
representation of what that growth curve
looks like so every day we would plant a
new row and move the rows up until we
finally ended up with a complete
picture of what every stage of the the
production looked like
we did the same for floating
systems
in the meantime we had visited a grower
in canada that was using these floating
systems and we we quickly realized the
benefits of this system
and and so we started working
on floating systems as well and here you
see the same idea
a visual representation of the growth
curve of lettuce plants in that floating
system
and then eventually and i'm sure
everybody here is familiar with us we
were able to and i think i still think
this is very remarkable out of the
research that we did
and this is to the credit of professors
uh langhans and and albright
they were able to convince our our
sponsors that it was a good idea to
build a demonstration facility and i
thought i don't think there are many
uh research projects that ultimately end
up in a significantly scaled
demonstration facility in which we were
going to demonstrate that this lattice
production system was going to work out
and that at that stage
the professor retired and i and i left
cornell
for for rutgers university so i'm
switching now to uh some of the work
that i've been involved with at rutgers
university and you quickly can see that
i'm switching to a totally different
crop
rutgers is is more known for their work
on tomatoes so when i came there i had
to switch my thinking from a
vegetative crop to a flowering crop like
like tomatoes and this is not a
particularly good picture of a tomato
plant but it has one feature that i
wanted you to look at which is the fact
that the stem here
is is cut and and the ruckus approach
was
a different approach for the traditional
tomato production system in the sense
that they decided to grow single cluster
or dual cluster
tomato plants and that meant that after
the first fruit cluster had started to
develop they would break off the
the growing tip
and and let the plant put all its
resources into
into
the few fruit that it was developing
before the plant was then discarded so
the cropping cycle was much
reduced in terms of time
but also the spacing was much increased
we could pack these plants much closer
together
in the system that we were looking at at
least theoretically it appeared that a
system like this would be as productive
as the more traditional lean and lower
system that is that you can see in most
commercial greenhouse operations
so i'm switching to a tomato crop
some of the early work was funded by
nasa
and this is also a bit of a contentious
point uh with the cornell group here
at the time uh rutgers had a an end
scored project and and
nasa funded project
where cornell also uh
was in the running and trying to get the
funding but it went to rutgers at the
time
and so um by leaving here i lucked out
and and and ended up being part of that
that
the winning effort at rutgers although
when i was here at uh
at cornell i was at the losing end
because we didn't get the funding
but anyway from a nasa point of view
and you have to think now about growing
crops for space applications where you
if you do long duration space missions
you you want to be able to provide your
crew with with nutritious food and it's
probably not likely that you can bring
uh as it is economical to bring all your
food with you so you have to produce as
you are traveling for example the mars
it becomes important to know more about
these crops and so nasa was interested
in funding some research and looking at
these crops and so
what we discovered when we looked at
this and when we started working in this
area that if you if you look at
published work in most cases people have
have looked at tomato production
extensively but the conditions under
which the tomatoes were grown under were
always kept constant in other words you
had certain set points that you
typically followed to to produce a crop
and and nasa of course was interested in
in developing growth models that they
can then use to try to simulate what the
production might be when you fly
a system like that in space because they
wanted to start planning how much food
they could count on for the crews that
they were planning to take with them
and so we needed to have
growth models
for those particular applications but we
also knew that in the nasa system
it might not be inconceivable that there
were perturbations to those
environmental conditions because for
example the power that was required to
run the lights was needed for another
critical component in their in their
system
and so the perturbations were really
important and and we knew that the
perturbation studies were not done very
extensively certainly not on tomato
crops
and then by talking to our specialists
on tomato crops we knew that
the environmental conditions
environmental conditions during
flowering and fruit set were really
important and that starts around 55 days
after seeding for the particular system
that we were using
so those conditions if you if you do
perturbations in that time period and
that for our case it was about a
two-week time period then that can have
significant impact on on the quality and
the and the yield of the plants
and we also looked at harvesting the
plants at the typical breaker stage
which for a tomato plant means that the
color is just changing from green to to
slightly orange or pinkish
and as harvesting at a later date
because we felt and we had indications
that if you wait longer
you get better qualities aspects of your
of your fruit production and so indeed
as you can see on the bottom point here
we did find that there were significant
improvements if you wait longer
before you start harvesting the fruit
which is obviously not a major
surprise but it was it was nice that we
could now
have a quantitative way of of showing
this
so the work was done in growth chambers
mostly
so very familiar to the growth chambers
that you use at cornell here
we used a lot of mylar screening around
our plant stands to try to overcome the
issue of sight lighting so typically you
would have sight lighting issues and you
would remove
plants on the outside rows from your
experiments but since we had limited
area we wanted to include those plants
so we used those screens to to try to
overcome the side light issue
and
the way we did it we started plants all
in the same growth chamber and then
depending on the treatment they were
moved to different uh growth chambers to
to receive their treatment so of course
there are issues associated with when
you start moving plants you you disturb
them you stress them and and we had to
take that into account so it was not a
particularly easy
thing to do but we made the best of the
resources that we had available
and for those of you insiders in
controlled environment
work you can see here that we used
fluorescent lamps and incandescent lamps
and
knowing from my time at cornell that
that the use of incandescent lamp is
somewhat contentious and i tried really
hard to convince my colleagues that we
should not be using them
but i lost obviously an argument and so
this is perhaps an institutional and
historical artifact that we still use
incandescent lamps for
for tomato production
switching to a different project but
still staying with the same crop
just like many other
universities including cornell
we were interested in high tunnel
production growers were interested in
particularly
and we got some seed money from our
college to investigate high tunnel
production
and we looked at
different sites we installed them in
different places across the state to
look at
different weather conditions
we looked at different orientations we
looked at tunnels with manual roll-up
sides we looked at tunnels with
automatic roll-up sides which meant you
had to have a motorized system with a
thermostat that would operate the
roll-up sides we looked at different
mulches different collet mulches for
tomato production
and and as you can see in the bottom
here we wrote an article
looking at additional
control measures such as an energy
curtain
that you would pull over the crop at
night to try to
maintain the temperature a little bit
longer
at optimum conditions or at least at
good growing conditions
as a side note i think we of course penn
state is really heavy and really big in
high tunnel research
we have been doing a little bit of it i
know that cornelis is doing a lot of
work in it too it seems to me that
across the region there should be more
collaboration among the various
institutions to try to
to not duplicate efforts because i think
some of that is going on at these
institutions
when i came to rutgers i inherited
a greenhouse shell so it wasn't looking
as nice as it looks in this picture
my predecessor was able to get funding
for the framework of a open roof
greenhouse system which is a newer
design that allows for
large amounts of air exchange to try to
keep the temperature inside pretty much
the same as outdoor conditions in the
summertime
which is typically not feasible when you
use mechanical ventilation systems
but if you have these open roof
greenhouses you can
get to
those conditions
so we
quickly
realized we needed to improve this
facility to get it up to a research
great facility and and gene reese
my graduate student and um technician at
the time
uh
did the yeoman's work of getting this
facility in great shape
to do experimentation and as you can see
from the the reference here he also
looked into
a a heating system a floor heating
system
uh and look at the benefits of floor
heating for for crop production
so here you see the inside of greenhouse
it's a an ebon flood floor system which
is a very nice way of irrigating your
crop if you can grow them in pots and
sitting directly on the floor
and then embedded in that concrete layer
we installed a heating system a a
plastic pipe system through which we
pump uh hot water
and the way that system was designed is
shown in this graphic so you have your
concrete slab you have the heating pipes
and you have also the the the supply and
drainage system for your irrigation
system that ends up in an underground
storage tank
where you store your nutrient solution
to be ready for the next
irrigation cycle
so the top of the floor was carefully
designed so it had a good drainage
system we call it a w shape we had two
rows of holes down the length of the the
bay
that collect the nutrient solution after
the irrigation cycle and then drains it
back into the tank and we pump the
nutrient solution through the same
system back up onto the floor when the
plants require water
as i mentioned gene did a lot of work on
on developing a numerical model
and this is of course engineering
talk
to look at
how the heat is distributed in in these
systems and here you see
a section of a floor slab
as the box the bar and then some red
dots indicating the location of the
heating pipes and the colors are
indicating the different temperatures
at a particular moment in this
simulation run so you get an idea of the
type of work we did using that system
some of the results of those simulations
are shown in this graph
where on the horizontal axis you look at
the supply water temperature
and it's it's not likely that you will
ever go as high as 55 or 60 degrees
because at that temperature you will
likely cook the crop that sits on the
floor but you might go as high as about
50 degrees or so
but what we're looking at here is how
much heat is actually coming off the
surface the top surface of the floor and
how much heat is going
uh is directed towards the the bottom or
the under layer the under layer of
ground underneath the floor represented
by the blue lines
because we were interested in the
question do you need to insulate
underneath a concrete floor to try to
prevent heat from escaping to the
outside that you can't use for
heating your greenhouse environment
and then in addition to that we looked
at and we could do this of course
because we had a simulation model we
looked at two different
pipe designs one we will use three
quarter inch pipes at
12 inch spacings
or we used which is more common these
days a half inch diameter pipe
at nine inch spacings so these are just
design features that you can incorporate
in your floor heating system
and you see there are some differences
the the the
between between those two uh conditions
but more importantly i think what i'm
trying to show you here is that about
approximately 10 of the heat that we
were able to supply in this floor
heating system would end up in the soil
underneath the remaining 90 of the heat
would actually end up in the
in the greenhouse environment and so
based upon that
fact we can now start looking at
recommending to growers to install an
insulating layer underneath the floor to
try to prevent that of course when the
floor is or the ground underneath the
floor is relatively dry
dry soil is not a very good heat
conductor
you may not need the insulation but if
you have a wet soil where particularly
if the soil moisture is a movement
continuously
you can significantly lose heat
from underneath the floor and therefore
in those cases a layer of insulation
might be very
desirable
and then the next step we took is
i showed you the diagram of the the
simulated slab we simulated a layer of
soil on that slab simulating
plug production and we looked at the
temperature distribution
in that layer of soil that simulated
layer of soil at different heights so
you see the temperature scale on the
left hand side
and so the bottom
green lines represent the highest
location in the two-inch layer of soil
that is sitting directly on the floor
and the the blue lines the top lines
represent the location closest to the
floor
and you can see here for the two
different designs where you have the 12
inch spacings with a little bit bigger
pipe or a little bit smaller pipe at the
shorter spacing of nine inches
represented by the rs and the s the
return on the supply lines in the bottom
of the graph
you can see here that the peaks
represe
coincide with where the supply lines are
installed and the valleys
are represented with where the return
lines are installed so that that all
matches up but what is more important i
think is to look at the fluctuation so
even though we have a very uniform
heating system
with the the simulation model we can now
start calculating exactly what the
temperature would be in our simulated
soil
layer and we could from that could could
make some assessment of whether these
fluctuating temperatures will have an
impact on on plant production
another project i'm involved with is a
micro turbine project and a micro
turbine is nothing more than a jet
engine in a box it's a stationary jet
engine
and it works on the same principle
we provide it with gas
and
it combusts the gas and as a result
it drives a turbine that generates
electricity we can use the electricity
on site we can export the electricity to
the grid or we can do a combination of
the two
so we're using landfill gas
landfill gas was initially
just
let go as the landfill is closed and and
bacteria break down
the refuge
methane gas is produced
that methane gas initially was just let
go to the environment but we quickly
realized that
that contributed significantly to
greenhouse gases and now nationwide we
have legislation that you can't do that
anymore you have to burn the gas
at least that's what's been done up
until now mostly most recently that's
that means they flared it
but of course then you waste it you
convert it to a still a greenhouse gas
co2 which is less of a greenhouse gas
than methane gas less potent
um so from that point of view it's good
but of course you waste that energy and
so we tapped into that resource
and and designed designed this this
micro turbine system
the challenge is if you use landfill gas
it's not as clean as natural gas
and so you need to clean it up
in order not to do damage to the
some of the critical components of the
of the turbine system
and so we need to remove sulfur gas and
you see two large cylinders here that
contain a
proprietary material
that probably contains a lot of iron
filings that is able to strip out
passively the sulfur gas the sulfur
and and then we go through a a
compression cycle and a refrigeration
cycle
to collect the moisture in the gas but
also more importantly the siloxane
chemicals a group of chemicals based on
silicate
that is it can be very detrimental to
engine components so we
we collect those we take them out
and then the remainder of the gas is
clean enough to be combusted in the
micro turbine system
you can see here it was a relatively
expensive
undertaking about a three quarters of a
million dollar unit
but it generates a fair amount of
electricity
that we can use for the supplemental
lighting system in the greenhouse
and if we we don't need that we can
export it to the grid and get a fairly
decent price for for the electricity
that way
it is commissioned as i show here in
2008 and we have some long-term data
operating it now
i can't take any credit for that but
because i started talking about energy i
wanted to show you that we have some
progressive growers in the state of new
jersey as well as we have in new york
this grower
was using
oil fuel oil as a as a fuel source for
his greenhouse operation that's about
seven acres
and um
because of the increases in oil prices
he is not no longer able to
economically
use that fuel source to to run his
operation so he switched over
to biomass energy
and he wants to eventually get to a
point where he's using
miscanthus or or switchgrass as the
biomass feedstock for for his operation
so he has 200 acres on site that he he's
planning to convert to
miscanthus and and
switchgrass
in the meantime he's using wood pellets
and so you can see here what porch
pellet looks like and you see the truck
delivering the wood pallas to two large
silos and then from the silos that get
organ gets ordered into a boiler system
that he uses to to run his operation
so we see a lot of growers struggling
with the energy
issue and and here's an example of how a
progressive grower was able to
convert
from from fuel oil to to biomass oil the
only challenge is and he's still
fighting this a little bit is that
because of his he's combusting biomass
he now has to deal with new air
regulations from our state dep
air quality issue is is important in new
jersey we have
we have issues with that and so our dep
is very strict about that so the
permitting issues associated with the
conversion from his oil system to this
biomass system
although realistically there are not
that many more
um
contributing components that he is
releasing into the environment just a
permitting issue because he has a
biomass type combustion system has been
have been very
challenging for him
aj are those mainly particulates or yep
yep
we also started to dabble a little bit
in led lighting i got a little seed
grant from the college
and as you can see here in a very
simplistic way we had a very little
money in that seat funding
we purchased a bunch of off-the-shelf
screw-in type led bulbs and
started to grow some tomato plants
and you can see here as the tomato
plants are getting taller and getting
close to the lamps you see certain areas
that are clearly red and clearly blue
the two colors that are typically used
to try to improve
plant growth and development
and
obviously this is not an ideal situation
but there's an interesting side note and
maybe this means something maybe it
doesn't
the two
tomatoes that you see here one growing
mostly under blue light and the other
one growing mostly on the red light were
not different from each other the
quality aspects and the and the
production aspects were no different
they were obviously on the same plant
but they were getting for significant
amount of time
significantly different color light
provided to them
and then before i move on i should say
that
i i'm participating now in a much larger
effort looking at led systems for
for greenhouse production
with a group of people from different
universities carrie mitchell at purdue
and others at purdue eric runkle and
michigan state
the group of gene giacomelli and cherry
kubota at arizona
and and myself at rutgers we are we're
trying to look at
a comprehensive study both from the
plant aspect as from the engineering
aspect on what we need in terms of led
lighting systems for for the greenhouse
industry
and i also was involved
for many years now with an international
committee that looked at guidelines for
controlled environments if you work in
controlled environments you realize that
when you when you read the literature
people not always report all the
critical
environmental parameters that they need
to report in order for you to understand
at least get a detailed understanding of
the experiments and also
for you to be able to replicate that
experiment so we have for many years
with an international group looked at
developing guidelines here you see the
example for experiments in growth rooms
and growth chambers
we have developed several of these
guidelines now for growth rooms and
growth chambers as well as for tissue
culture facilities and we're working on
a guideline for
for greenhouse production as well
and what we are really
trying to get after is to have a a table
like this
where researchers can look at the
different parameters that are important
for plant production which you see on
the left hand side here
they understand what units they need to
use to measure those parameters
correctly
where to measure those conditions
when to measure them and what to report
not only in their reports to funding
agency but perhaps more importantly in
their reports to the scientific
community through papers and
presentations so this is an ongoing
effort and although it's a fairly
thankless effort i think it's an
important effort because hopefully
it will bring the entire research
community
more in line with each other so that we
can better understand and use each other
results
then moving on to my sabbatic in the
netherlands and here you see a pretty
picture of
one of their greenhouse facilities that
is growing roses
i think
if you want to see rose production in
the netherlands you should be quick
because i think just like in the united
states
the costs are prohibitive uh and are
getting it's getting more and more
difficult for growers to continue this
this type of business and so i wouldn't
be surprised in the next 10 to 20 years
the entire rose production would
disappear from the netherlands
i i uh worked with uh my old department
the yagas junior department called now
the farm technology group which has
become part of the plant sciences group
and for those of you who
know a little bit about the netherlands
the way their system is set up is quite
differently than we have
our system here and in the united states
and so i wanted to take a few minutes to
explain a little bit
how the system operates and how it's put
together the plan sciences group
consists of the university wageningen
university and research center wrur
and then the plant sciences group in
particular there's also a group called
the plant research international and the
applied plant research group or ppo
so all these entities the university
the the former extension
government research facilities are all
combined in a sort of convoluted
organization
called the plant sciences group
you see the locations the main locations
as well as their field trial stations
and i wanted to give you some sense of
the the value of the horticulture
industry in the netherlands and
particularly for bill miller i added
bulbs as well hopefully my numbers are
correct but here you see uh the the
monetary value of the exports both to
the world and as a subset of that within
the european union
the export the the dollar the the in
this case the euro amounts
uh associated with these exports and i
for reference i give you the
uh the gross domestic products of the
netherlands
it's a the contribution that
horticulture is making to the country is
very significant and hence perhaps the
the the uh
the top position that that the
netherlands
maintains up until today in this field
they have very nice new facilities the
the organization in wageningen has also
completely changed they are building an
entirely new campus and the plant
sciences group as you can see here has a
very wonderful new facility with large
greenhouse operations as well
so they really put a lot of effort into
getting people up to speed and having
the world-class facility there
and then if you really wanted to know
more about the specifics this is
something i got out of a canned
presentation by the plant sciences group
they have four
specific focus areas sustainable
production and climate change
plant-based materials health and systems
biology and you can read off under each
of these four areas the specific areas
that they target at these are the main
areas that they try to focus their
research on so they are they're not
doing
everything anymore for everybody they
have specifically targeted areas where
they feel they can make a significant
contribution
unlike in the united states in the
netherlands
they have a wonderful statistical
service that collects many many data
points not only for the greenhouse
industry but for many industries
and so there's a wealth of data
available there about what the
greenhouse
industry is doing and i wanted to show
you
several sets of slides
indicating what the trends are
because i think there are some very
interesting trends going on and in very
recent years so you're looking here at
three different years in 2000 2005 and
2009 that was the last year i found data
four
and you can by the way you can get this
annual updated data yourself you have to
pay about 150 euros or so to get a nice
book that contains many very interesting
facts about the industry
so if you need this kind of data i can i
can point you in the right direction
but what you're looking at here is the
the number of operations and the
particular size of these operations and
if you look at the data carefully then
you see that all sizes are declining
rapidly except for the very largest size
so what you're seeing here is that the
number of greenhouse operations is
declining overall but we see
more of the remaining greenhouses become
larger and larger and this is a very
recent development it used to be that
the average size was around a hectare in
the netherlands and it was that for a
long time
but now in the last 10 years or so you
see you see a significant change in that
so we get fewer companies but the
companies that are remaining are larger
and then i also separated out on the
bottom here comparing the vegetable
versus the others because the vegetables
obviously are of interest to myself so
we see the same trend in the vegetable
production the number of vegetable
operations is significantly declining
over the last 10 years but the the size
of the individual operations is is
increasing and increasing quite
substantially
if you look at the overall production
area in the netherlands that has
remained the same around 10 000 hectares
but again you see some interesting
changes in the the first set of
bars you see that the vegetable
production is significantly increases
so is so is there an increase in
flowering pot plants but you see the cut
flowers
is significantly declining and hence my
comment earlier about the rose
production i think it becomes it is
becoming too expensive
to grow cut flowers in the netherlands
and and so this is this is why i think
you won't see
very many rose growers in the next 10 to
20 years anymore
if you look at the
vegetable production you see a similar
trend although here we see an increase
particularly because of tomato increase
in pepper increase
and strawberries is mentioned here also
obviously strawberry is not considered a
vegetable but for the dutch industry
it's the it's one of the few
fruits that are grown in greenhouses so
for convenience they're typically
grouped in with vegetable production so
you see
some of the vegetables are increasing
others others not so much
when you look at the cut flower and the
pop plant area we see again roses
declining chrysanthemums declining and
other crops declining
so overall the cut flowers are declining
but the pot embedding plants are are
keeping steady or perhaps slightly
increasing so again it's it's an
interesting trend that is occurring
comparing holland to one of the other eu
countries where lots of greenhouse
production is going on in the spain
you see here that the production in
spain in terms of area really dwarfs
what's going on in the netherlands
so keep that in mind and keep in mind
i'm talking about vegetable production
here
one of the reasons is that of course if
you look at a particular reason the
almeria region in spain we see a very
significant increase in the in the last
40 years or so in greenhouse production
area in that particular location this is
the the main factor why why spain is so
much so much more of a bigger producer
compared to the netherlands and we see
we see
and as a result of course we see a shift
in
in focus when you look at the european
union in terms of where where fruits and
vegetables are produced
auction prices are always interesting to
look at and what i really want you to
take home from this slide is when you're
looking at two different years and
several types of tomatoes round tomatoes
cherry tomatoes and on the vine tomatoes
but the the challenge here as we would
have in the united states is that you
see significant fluctuations from year
to year and you see significant
fluctuations
uh from season to season so
what we always hoped for with our
lettuce system is that because we could
deliver consistently
there would be a consistent price
associated with that consistent delivery
that is not happening in the netherlands
and it's not going to happen anytime
soon in the netherlands either i think
so
growers are forced to
deal with this situation as a result it
continues to be a very challenging
production system because some years you
get a good price in some years you get a
bad price and how do you deal with that
from an economic point of view
we see a lot of growers
using combined heat and power systems in
the netherlands
and that was historically because gas
prices were relatively inexpensive
and so it made sense because they used
lots of supplemental lighting and used
more and more of it
in the last decade or so
these are expensive systems
but they were economical at the time
in fact in 2010 about 12 percent of the
national electricity consumption was
produced by greenhouses well think about
that that is really a significant
contribution from these
individual systems installed at
greenhouse operations
more recently we see that the gas prices
have increased because they are more
tied to oil prices in in europe than
they are here and we see lots of growers
getting in trouble because this system
is no longer as profitable as it used to
be so they have these expensive systems
installed they have multi-year
projections for how they're going to pay
them back and all of a sudden
the situation changes the gas prices is
more expensive than i anticipated
electricity prices have not gone up as
high as they had hoped and as a result
they get into trouble
keeping with the theme of of lighting
we
and i've i've looked at lighting systems
in the netherlands and this is the the
latest
approach that they're taking into canopy
lighting using led systems
not only led lighting but still
maintaining overhead high pressure
sodium lighting to grow a crop
whether this is the the ultimate
approach i'm not so sure but at least
this is the latest
technology latest state of the art which
they are trying out and and they're
claiming they're getting good results
although i haven't seen many published
publications about this yet
there was a food safety issue that i
wanted to mention that happened just
before we came um an e coli infestation
and it had significant implications in
in
the on the industry
it turned out to be a fenugreek seed
that was imported from from egypt that
was grown on organic farm in germany but
it took several weeks to discover
the cause of of the infestation and as a
result what they needed to do about and
in the meantime many other crops were
implicated as the source for this food
contamination
and as a result
the entire production came to a grinding
halt
lots of fruits and vegetables had to be
discarded and as a result many growers
got into severe financial
difficulty and in fact we see a
large number of greenhouse operations
that had to shut down
and close completely as a result of this
food scare so this is just a
precaution we've had these food scares
in the united states as well not
typically for greenhouse operations but
more for field production but this is an
example on how
a completely unrelated event it had
nothing to do with greenhouse production
nothing to do with crops that we
typically grow in greenhouses
had a significant impact on the industry
to the point where we see growers going
out of business
then moving on to some future directions
and i put in this picture because i
think we should always be moving forward
but before i get into my suggestions i i
i think we have to go back and look at
what's going on and so i like to show
this slide
looking at population growth that you
should well be familiar to all of you
when professor langhans was born around
the time we had 2 billion people living
on this planet by now we have 7 billion
and in the next
almost 40 years or so by 2050 we will
have 9 billion people
i was born in 1960 so there was a
already a billion increase compared to
when professor langhans was born
so this is something this is reality
this is not going to change and this is
something we have to deal with and when
i was in the netherlands i
i picked up on an
inaugural address that's what they do in
the netherlands when a new professor
is installed in his position they give a
speech and he gave a speech
talk about this issue
and he mentioned that if if by 2050 we
want everybody the 9 billion people that
will be living on earth and we want
everybody to eat
using european standards this is
probably not going to happen but use it
as a reference point
so have the access to food and the
quality
of the food that europeans are
accustomed to we need to triple our
production
that is a that is a tall order
now as i said we may not we may not get
to european levels but that we have to
increase production
should be evident and so this is reality
this is something we have to deal with
the other thing we have to deal with is
that we're not creating more land we
have limited amount of area available to
grow our crops at and if you look at the
different regions of the world here and
you look at particularly the croplands
or the
brownish
orange
like
bar here
you see that we have very limited
areas set aside for crop production
in fact i think
on a world
scale
it's perhaps 0.2 hectares
per person that is available for crop
production and if we add more people of
course that number becomes even smaller
and smaller and smaller so land
becomes a critical issue as well and
obviously
water is a very critical issue one
percent of the earth's water is
available
as fresh water readily available as
fresh water
a lot of that
by far the biggest part of it is
consumed by agriculture we can do a lot
better in certain
irrigation systems in terms of
efficiency but as of now a lot of that
water that we have available is used for
agriculture
greenhouses of course
allow for better control of water uptake
but nevertheless if you look at our
lettuce data
it requires two and a half liters of
water to grow one five ounce head of
lettuce so that's a significant amount
of water that we need
to grow as simple plant as lettuce
so the fact remains that we need large
quantities of water
to grow our crops whether we do it in a
greenhouse or not
greenhouse production comes a long way
again around the time that professor
langhans was born we we saw a lot of
cold frames
obviously that required a lot of labor
you see a large crew there working
in the netherlands we had
greenhouses specifically designed for
seed grapes so for for consumption
grapes
and you see also
some older greenhouses on the left hand
side for carnations and on the
right-hand side for tomato production
in a traditional old-fashioned system
when professor langhans came to cornell
in the early 50s
cornell looked something like this you
could still park your car in front of
willett straight and there was a parking
lot on the egg quad
by the way
ken poster was still working at the time
he see a picture of ken post
from 1951 so a year before professor
langhas came
came here and you see this the state of
the greenhouse
i have to add to that when i came in the
in the late 80s the greenhouse didn't
look much different
obviously
some of them some of them obviously some
of them have improved so talking about
parking
if you live in a in a densely populated
area
then you're dealing with this issue so
this is another example of the increase
in population growth and the challenges
that we are are facing uh we are faced
with
dealing with that increase
going back to the greenhouses we see
lots of
uh developments lots of technology that
that is in use today that really make
these very highly sophisticated and
high-tech systems
so just to name some examples you see
the greenhouse on the upper left-hand
side
a design that doesn't use any gutters
anymore the greenhouse is designed so
that the glass panes the very large
glass panes actually form or gutter
themselves
and the trusses are not running
across the base but are running in the
length of the bay actually supporting
the area where normally the gutter would
be and the trusses is the truss is
designed in such a way that it provides
a space for the energy current to be
stored in
again to try to maximize light
transmission through this system so
there's a very
uh
specific design features that allow for
maximum light transmission in this
highly modern greenhouse we have
sophisticated on the upper right hand
side we have sophisticated
irrigation systems here you see an
entire table being moved by a
computerized system to an irrigation
station the funnel there
would be supplied with the right amount
of water and nutrients for the
the gerbera crop to grow optimally in
this in this system so the the computer
decides when the crop needs irrigation
and then moves the table to an
irrigation station
to provide it with water and nutrients
we have very sophisticated robots we
call them flat fixtures the the that's
that that
make sure that every cell in a plug tray
is filled with a viable plant so there's
a camera system that inspects an entire
tray
a mechanical system that takes out the
tray the cells that were not germinated
or have diseased plants and then refills
those open spaces with
with viable plants to make sure that
when a grower sells a flat 100 of the
plants in that flat are actually viable
for the next stage of production and
then ultimately on the lower right hand
side we have high throughput greenhouses
in which plants are grown in individual
containers that are that are kept track
of by a computer system so these plants
can be manipulated individually
in the greenhouse system for
for measurements and and
and handling so
very expensive but highly
uh computerized and and
automated systems to to make sure we can
handle plants very efficiently without
uh much human interaction
so
to come to some conclusions um
i think to help feed
the growing world
to me it seems greenhouse food
production is a is going to be a
critical component in that
however i think
despite the need and i think the
demonstrated capabilities as i've tried
to indicate in this talk
there's there's
limited funding
and and also i think we have we we don't
have the support from college
administrators that itself could be an
entire presentation uh but uh i think i
think you understand what i'm talking
about
so what do we need to do i think i think
as a group as a as a group of scientists
working in controlled environments we
need to become stronger advocates for
greenhouse production i think we need to
find a way to tell our story better and
to tell it to people that really matter
and that can then take action to help us
with funding and help
further the cause
another area i think and i strongly
believe in this and where we can make
improvements is to to increase our
collaborations
locally regionally but also
internationally
and i think
you may have heard a lot of discussion
recently about vertical farming
um i don't necessarily think vertical
farming is a bad idea but i certainly
don't think it's a great idea
but i think we need to come up as a
group with a viable alternative
in addition and i get to back to
vertical farming in a second in addition
i think we need to look at our
inputs and we need to look at the
efficient use of our inputs we need to
reduce energy consumption
and waste we need to increase the
biodegradable materials the use of them
and we need more recycling in our
industry
we are working on those issues but i
don't think we we we do enough of it yet
because i think if we don't
outsiders will do it for us and of
course when outsiders start looking at
us
they may come up with different ideas
and different outcomes and outcomes that
may not be always in in the
in to the benefit of the greenhouse
industry
so we need to look at things like life
cycle assessments of our production
systems we know we use a lot of energy
we know significant resources
particularly water
and we need to look at the life cycle
assessment of those
production processes and include things
like carbon footprints and other
environmental impacts to come to a a
transparent and fair assessment of what
we're doing because i think
if we don't do that others will
and others may question why we are using
significant resources for example
to produce non-essentials and i think a
a rose crop in the greenhouse
or perhaps even a lettuce crop in the
greenhouse could be labeled by outsiders
as a non-essential crop
and i think if that happens
we're going to have a long way fighting
ourselves back and trying to make sure
that those those industries remain
viable
because i think if once we get into a
negative consumer
perception case
and there are examples of that in our
industry
if we get to that point it's going to be
very hard to
to fight those perceptions and to
to get back on top again
so back to vertical farming
i found this
reference and
some pictures
i don't think vertical farming is a new
idea here you see an idea by
a professor in australia in austria i'm
sorry
from the early 60s
looking at a conveyor system in a
vertical tower
trying to grow crops using supplemental
lighting to help
speed up production
so i think the vertical farming is not a
new
idea here you see a modern version of
what a vertical farm looked like in an
urban area so the idea is you produce it
close to to densely populated centers
you produce it in
a hydroponic system
but minimizing really the the
transportation distance
between where you produce it and where
it's consumed
so is it a good idea
you should ask professor albright to
give a talk because he can give a very
nice talk telling you that it's not a
good idea i tend to agree with him
but nevertheless it's an idea that's out
there and it's being promoted
by lots of people so i think we need to
deal with it as i said i think we need
to come up with a viable alternative to
to counteract some of the forces that
are trying to push push this further
professor albright says that an
alternative might be to to look at what
he calls perry urban agriculture so
still have food production close to
large population centers but not
grow them right inside the population
center but we grow them at the perimeter
so
at the outside of the densely populated
areas i think that's a good idea what i
am
proposing is in addition to that to also
revisit the idea of having greenhouses
attached to residential living spaces
and not thinking about this as a as a an
afterthought where a greenhouse is put
in the backyard or a greenhouse is
attached to a home like a sunroom but
really
looking at an integration of both the
greenhouse system with the living
environment so involve architects and
designers
involve plant scientists involve
agriculture engineers that know
something about greenhouses
and sit around the table and develop a
system
that makes the takes benefit of the of
the heat that's being generated by the
greenhouse and use that in the building
system
but obviously also
provide for an opportunity for the
family or the residents of the the
structure to grow a certain number of
crops in that space
to hopefully make them become less
dependent on traditional supply chains
and i only have to point to the recent
disaster that we had in new jersey and
new york
with hurricane sandy
to to come to the realization that it is
important for most of us
uh to realize how dependent we are on
some of these traditional supply chains
and the
uh the shock that it creates when those
supply chains disappear
it was a major shock and it still is a
major shock to our system in new jersey
and it's going to take quite some time
to overcome that i went to the grocery
store on friday and the lights were all
dimmed there was no fresh produce and
this is almost two weeks after the event
no fresh produce
all the cooling cases were emptied there
were no frozen products at all in the
store it was it felt like a third world
country that i walked into
and so the disruption of an event like
what we had and granted this is not
happening too often but we know it can
happen and we are we're faced with it i
think
that
makes
it all the more relevant and all the
more critical that we look at
alternative ways of providing ourselves
with food and energy and other critical
components
so with that and with this picture that
was
made
several years ago by van gogh that i
think strengthens the theme that i
wanted to point out to
which is local and small agriculture
perhaps we need to revisit that idea and
how we can incorporate
small agriculture back into our modern
way of living
i want to close and i want to point out
that
obviously i'm standing as i present to
you here
on on many tall
and giant shoulders here
so i want to
express my gratitude for all the work
that was done for people that came
before me but also many colleagues that
i've worked with both here and elsewhere
through my journey so thank you very
much
aeroponics
um
the the only research i'm familiar with
is the work that's being done in the
university of arizona and i'm not too
familiar with it um
obviously uh
disney world in
florida has been promoting aeroponics
for quite some time and have shown that
it can be successful
the challenge is that
if if the system fails if the pump
doesn't pump and doesn't irrigate uh the
routes continuously
uh you you have a very short amount of
time in which you can react and respond
and overcome that issue so
in terms of having a system that can
that can deal with hiccups which we
always have in these complicated systems
it's it's it's delicate and so i think
for commercial operations we haven't
seen many people go that route although
we know that
if the system operates properly they can
be successful
apple and lettuce
let's look at pure at efficiency so i
looked at the amount of light that was
received by the crop and the dry metal
production and that's how i compare the
two so pure from an efficiency point of
view
but your apple trees yes
yeah you have to go to the monteith
reference to get the details
correct yeah and so this works in the
netherlands but it may not work here
yeah so this is what i showed you what
they were doing in the netherlands and
and the reasons of course is that that
scaling up for them makes sense they
have to compete with imports from other
european countries particularly and so
in order to stay in business with this
high tech expensive system
they feel that our only way out is to to
scale up to have more production area
to become more efficient with that
system
but that may not work in our case for
sure you're right
no i agree with you the only thing i
want to add is that i think we have to
be careful when we use the word
sustainable because it means different
something different to different people
and so the the
the the
root of it is is important and i agreed
to
but i think
when i talk about sustainability it may
mean something different than when you
talk about sustainability and
and
if we if we want to make sure that
people understand
what sustainability is and from from
what point we're looking at it and how
we use it we need to have a common
definition and i think the definition is
being slowly watered down at the moment
and so that the term is i think
disputable i i agree with the concept
and it's important that we look at that
but the wording is is perhaps something
we need to look at
go ahead let's thank aj and get them
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu